entweder die nummer 3 5 oder 7 ist kacke
unsinn ich bin echt doof dass unser name
ist luca und name ist moment ich habe ja
noch gar keinen namen der strauß hat
noch immer keinen namen also ihr könnt
immer noch weiterhin abend für den
straßen die kommentare schreiben
wenn ich die tage im video zu machen
allerdings sind wir heute nicht hier
beisammen gekommen um uns über den namen
des straußes im hintergrund zu
unterhalten sondern meine damen und
herren ich habe auf youtube einen test
entdeckte den nur drei prozent aller
leute die diesen test machen wirklich
erfolgreich bestehen und beheizter
testet wie gute sind deine augen meine
augen sind relativ beschissen und von
daher werden wir heute schauen ob wir
diesen test hier meistern können also
wie gut sind deine augen nur drei
prozent werden diesen test schaffen
können aber ich habe auch schon gesagt
gehörst du zu diesen menschen ich denke
ehrlich gesagt eher nicht es gibt vier
stufen erstens einfach zweitens
mitteldrittels schwer und viertens
extrem jede stufe hat fünf fragen die
immer schwieriger werden bei jeder frage
werden zehn farben angezeigt eine der
anzeigt
du solltest wenn man deutsch test machen
eine dieser farben ist anders zum
beispiel hier ist halt die vier anders
und man muss dann die richtige farbe
auswählen um die frage zu bestehen wie
kann man eine frage bestehen
du kannst du eine frage beantworten du
kommst bloß dann weiter wenn du alle
fünf fragen einer stufe besteht ist das
heißt wir müssen alles schaffen jede
frage bei jeder stufe nicht so wie bei
den tests die ich sonst mal gemacht habe
wo man sage ich mal
da
erinnert natürliche siebenhaller case
ist jetzt gerade auf stufe eins frage 1
ich dass ich beantwortet hätte wäre ich
glaube ich bin aber ich finde es auf
jeden fall krass dass man hier um
weiterzukommen jede frage einer sprung
für richtig beantworten muss also es
wird zum ende hin wahrscheinlich
wirklich noch schwierig werden
hier ist farbe 4 natürlich anders wäre
das nicht die der brauch wirklich eine
brille oder überhaupt erst mal augen
also hier ist natürlich farbe vier auch
richtig als nächstes haben wir dann hier
eine farbskala wo die farbe acht dunkler
ist also stufe eins kann man eigentlich
war springen war aber acht war auch hier
wieder dunklere farbe dann hier
natürlich farbe 5 das sieht man ja
allein schon wenn das bild ein findet so
auch hier ist farbe fünf natürlich die
dunklere farbe das heißt wir sind glaube
ich jetzt schon bei frage für die frage
5 sogar hier ist farbe 9 anders
stufe eins haben bestanden alle fragen
gestellt und sollte dann auch noch
großgeschrieben wahrscheinlich sind
deine eltern nicht zufrieden mit wir
sind jetzt bei der stufe 2 der
schwierigkeitsgrad mittel das heißt es
ist auf jeden fall ein bisschen
schwieriger nun vom 2
ja immer noch relativ easy natürlich ist
hier farbe zwei auch ein anderer farbton
als die anderen gezeigten fragen die
nächste farbskala als sechs mal habe ich
einfach nur geile august das christ um
allerdings muss man halt auch sagen das
ist vier stufen gibt und wir sind gerade
bei stufe 2 hier ist die 3 meine ich
also es wird schon ein bisschen
schwieriger als schauen ob es zum ende
hin noch krasser wird also ich habe auf
jeden fall schon in den kommentaren
lesen können bei den ersten die
angezeigt wurden dass es bei extrem also
hier ist die zehn aber das ist wirklich
am ende bei der letzten stufe enorm
schwierig sein soll hier ist auch die
nummer 10 wieder ein anderer farbton als
die anderen gezeigte farben hier ist es
farben nummer acht
das ist schon schwierig gerade wir
müssen uns ja immer daran erinnern nur
wenn wir jede frage richtig haben können
wir weiter machen also auch hierfür
haben nummer acht war richtig in dem
fall
das heißt wir sind jetzt wenn du alle
fragen dieser stufe geschafft hatte der
tiger das ihr euch dann auch nicht
berichtigt stufe 3 schwierigkeitsgrad
schwer also das ist jetzt wirklich ein
komplett anderes level das ist
neu
also aus dem bauch heraus würde ich fünf
sagen ja ich ja ich würde sagen 51 ist
ja das nein das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr guck mal was ist das
für ein kleiner unterschied okay das
heißt die dritte stufe schaffe ich auf
jeden fall schon mal nicht weil die
ersten drei
also es ist leider schon amtlich die
dritte stufe habe ich mir direkt bei der
erste frage verkackt verdammt ich hatte
oasis die drei ich hatte erst gedacht
dass es die sechs ist weil das ein
hellerer farbton war aber die 5 hier ist
es die 8
jetzt die acht jahre ich glaube hier ist
ja ich habe wirklich bei der erste frage
gedacht hey ich kriege das hin ok kommen
hier ist die acht dann wenn man
zumindest sagen würde wenn man vier von
fünf richtig hätte die fünf ist diesmal
würde ich sagen
hier kann man das halt viel leichter
erkennen als bei der ersten frage finde
ich und bei der erste frage endlich regt
das auf ich dachte ich schaffe dieses
komplett weil jeder arzt mir mal gesagt
meine augen sind perfekt 4,5 habe auch
richte ich mich regt so was einfach nur
auf ich weiß es ist nur so ein charakter
youtube passt aber gut wir sind hier bei
der fünfte frage ich würde sagen 4
man sieht ihr sogar noch ein bisschen
dieses schwarze von photoshop also auch
hier ist die farbe für eine andere farbe
als die anderen
ich habe hier nicht alles geschafft wenn
ja dann kannst du besser contras kontra
st
denn
das ist echt wahnsinn ich habe euch den
test auch mal und in der beschreibung
verlinkt da könnt ihr das setzt aber
machen denn das hat anderthalb millionen
aufrufe also ich weiß nicht wie ein
video mit so vielen rechtschreibfehlern
soviel aufruf
becker
das ist alles die gleiche farbe wir sind
mittlerweile schon bei der stufe extrem
hier deswegen ist es natürlich auch
extrem schwierig hier einen unterschied
zu erkennen
wenn ich jetzt allerdings mal raten
müsste würde ich sagen 1 oder ziehen
oder ich sage das nur weil da halt
direkt die farbe am meisten mit dem
hintergrund verbunden ist wenn ich mich
jetzt entscheiden müsste würde ich sagen
ich würde sagen 222 ist anders 7
du bist echt absolut scheiße in nimmt
also in diesem fall hier würde ich nun
sagen dass die richtige antwort auf
diese frage entweder die nummer 3 5 oder
7 ist kacke wahnsinn ich bin echt doof
das ist echt gar nichts frage drei sind
wir mittlerweile schon von der stufe
extrem ich würde hier sagen die 116
liga ist er ist der mann
sid voll klar dass das hier heller ist
als hier das ist einfach ein verlauf ja
okay wenn man jetzt darauf achtet wie
bei den meisten strichen war sondern
linie hoch sie das ist schon ein
bisschen andere farbe aber bis sie kennt
kein mensch
egal wie gut die augen sind das erkennt
kein mensch ja also klar das ganze ist
jetzt hier natürlich kein medizinisch
wissenschaftlicher augen oder sehtest
oder irgendwie sowas aber
also
was soll hier die zwei sage ich
und zwar durch das hier mal an ich sehe
hier und besonders auch hier
es sind meine augen scheiße oder ich
sehe auch hier ein farbunterschiede
steht ich war damals mal beim optiker
weil ich das problem hatte dass sich
halt oft auf dem monitor geschaut habe
und danach halt irgendwie weiter in die
ferne geguckt habe oder am krassesten
was beispielsweise hat sich zum beispiel
zu hause ein video aufgenommen habt und
dann zum fußballtraining damals gefahren
bin vor ein paar jahren und dann konnte
ich halt auf lange entfernungen mich
mehr den ball richtig erkennen dafür
habe ich halt eine spezielle brille
bekommen die besonders fürs autofahren
halt geeignet war aber irgendwie habe
ich das problem mittlerweile nicht mehr
weil ich nicht mehr so viel auf dem
computer schauen warum sind jetzt so
viele haare
das ist von dem strom auf jeden fall
habe ich halt da einen normalen seht es
gemacht beim optiker und bei den werten
kam raus ist meine augen 1a perfekt sind
ich hatte halt nur dieses fokussierung
probleme nicht auf dem bildschirm
geguckt aber danach aufs handy und dann
wieder auf der straße oder auf längere
entfernungen von daher kann ich wirklich
sagen dass meine augen 1 a 100 prozent
funktionieren also wenn es hier wirklich
nach der sehkraft gehen würde dann würde
der kleine buchstaben angezeigt werden
hier geht's einfach nur da uns raten
drei sage ich 9 also sorry dieser ganze
tests wenn du diese stufe geschafft ich
dislike recht selten videos aber so ein
test also die extreme stufe am ende das
hat hier nichts mehr mit einem augen
test zu tun haben dann gehörst du zu den
drei prozent die alle stufen geschafft
haben also wenn man alles geschafft hat
das ist ja wahnsinn und dann noch so
viele rechtschreibfehler da drin
jetzt soll das vollständige ergebnis das
sind ergebnisse werden noch jede frage
nach einander da wurde die lösung
gezeigt also drei prozent schaffen es
überhaupt diese extreme stufe zu
vollenden nicht nur dahin zu kommen ich
weiß auch nicht wo die diese daten
hernehmen das ist genauso wie
fantastisch die irgendwas raus nur weil
sie faktisch heißen glaubt denen jeder
also das hier ist serie talk einfach nur
komplette bullshit
wie weit bist du gekommen ich glaube
stufe 3 war ich eine stufe schwärmen da
habe ich direkt die erste frage nicht
geschafft an der stelle welche das
heutige video jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
dieser test und auch meine reaktion und
meist dann mehr oder weniger von diesem
quiz gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier da das
würde mich sehr freuen schreibt mir
gerne mal eure meinung zu diesem test
und in die kommentare in meine meinung
dazu ist er bescheiden liegt unter dem
video gerne auf abonnieren dann werdet
ihr offizieller teil der luchs und sei
teil von der lockruf von wenn ihr schon
abonnenten
dann würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
auf die glocke klicken würde denn dann
bekommt der benachrichtigung direkt auf
ihr handy sobald ich ein neues video
hochladen und jetzt will ich sie auch
beenden
[Musik]